i'm gonna figure it all out i promise
you we're all all gonna learn a source
tells e.t khloe kardashian is quote
getting back on her a-game following her
ex tristan thompson recently admitting
to fathering a son with another woman
while he was still in a relationship
with her i'm not taking any from anyone
the source says the 37 year old reality
star has quote been spending time with
her sisters and family working out
eating healthy and focusing on her mind
body and soul as far as her relationship
with tristan the father of her
three-year-old daughter true the source
adds quote chloe and tristan's
relationship is strained she hardly
wants to give him any energy at the
moment tristan will always be part of
the family but at this point she is done
romantically speaking the family was
disappointed with tristan and just want
to be there for chloe chloe isn't
rushing to get back into the dating
world at this time i'm not here to play
chloe and tristan have been on and off
for years facing multiple cheating
scandals and this past summer the two
called it quits tristan later became the
subject of a paternity case with a woman
named marley nichols who claimed he
fathered her son while still in a
relationship with chloe something he
initially denied wasn't that crazy the
baby boy was born on december 1st and
earlier this month tristan confirmed he
is indeed the father of marley's child
after a paternity test was performed the
30 year old went on to make a public
apology to chloe with this statement he
shared on his instagram story he wrote
in part quote i take full responsibility
for my actions
chloe you don't deserve this you don't
deserve the heartache and humiliation i
have caused you you don't deserve the
way i have treated you over the years i
know another source previously told et
that chloe and tristan are only in touch
to discuss matters related to their
daughter saying quote chloe and tristan
are in touch about logistical things and
about what's going on with true and
that's really the focus when they're
communicating a second source adding
that tristan quote has been apologetic
and attempting to make things better
well when it comes to chloe's strategy
for staying positive amidst drama here's
what she told et in 2016. my secret is
just i think having a positive outlook
on life i guess i don't know i really
think it's just
like you wake up every morning and you
have a positive outlook and i like i
love to work out and i love to just like
that's my selfish time i want to be for
like the rest of my life i just want
that to be my routine that i wake up and
i go to the gym and i work on fitness
and just healthy like even your mental
you have to practice that you have to
that's a workout in itself i think is
making sure that you're that i
constantly am aware that i want to be
positive today i want to be a kind
person or you have to be i think aware
of that stuff
[Music]
you